I think we will get started I'm Shanna
care and the director of the vehicle
says I'd like to welcome all of you to
this very special event this evening I'd
like first of all to thank for joining
us here tonight to talk about his work
and a special thanks to Alessandro DG
Farrow and in particular for suggesting
that we that we invited achieve and for
bringing together four co-sponsors at
Columbia to make that happen
we're delighted that the musical says is
co-sponsoring this event with the Center
for oral history the Institute for the
Study of human rights and the European
Institute all at Columbia Alessandra
suggested that we invite French
choreographer and performance artist as
you have done to Columbia while he is in
New York for the performance of ordinary
witnesses and for world fair live Arts
Festival and the crossing the line
festival at via in his recent review New
York Times dance critic Alistair McAuley
says that ordinary witnesses a docudrama
blending dance video testimonies and
mixed-media extends the whole notion of
what dance can express and is quote
among the most remarkable dance theater
works of our time ordinary witnessess is
not directly related to the events that
occurred in Paris 50 years ago today on
October 17th 1961 when a peaceful
demonstration was brutally repressed by
the Parisian police and as many as 200
Algerians were killed these events were
the topic of a conference held here this
afternoon on the Paris massacre of
October 1961 and historic perspective
and that continues on Thursday evening
we will show October without EE the
legendary documentary by Jack Benny's
elevated 1962 and that will be presented
by Professor kilowatts but fortunate
timing meant that eventually was
available for a conversation here this
evening and the subject the subjects he
explores an ordinary witnesses carry
such strong echoes of today's conference
that inviting him here tonight seemed
like a fitting coda to the conference
the veg meat is French and was born to
Algerian parents and one of the
interesting connections is that the
initial inspiration for ordinary
witnesses was an interview that
conducted with his mother in which he
event that his father had been tortured
in the Algerian war and that figures in
an earlier piece that he performed there
are other connections as well speakers
earlier today explore the process of the
historical reconstruction of the Paris
massacre and its representation in
literature and film the Beckett's work
to explores how acts of extreme physical
violence and repression
can be remembered and communicated how
they can be represented in his case the
process involved conducting interviews
with survivors of war
torture and mass killings from Rwanda to
Brazil and transforming these
testimonies into a performance that
blurs the boundaries between death dance
and documentary why dance as Alistair
McCauley puts it in his review what his
dance got to do with genocide or torture
while I for that matter concern
ourselves as we did today with the
events with how the events of October 17
1961 have been represented in film and
literature why not just tell the history
strew straight and truthfully with words
to quote the Rwandan survivor who speaks
at the beginning of ordinary witnesses
words can't possibly translate
happened set dance Illuminati Bible
circling moves some heavier points for
me and if you manage to express it and
even if you find someone interested in
it they might not believe it and even if
they believe you they might not know
what to do with it I don't know what to
do with my memories and others can't
know what to do with them watch people
have done will be introduced Alessandra
reached her procedure degree from D AMS
the School of Performing Arts in Bologna
Italy she's a dance writer and
translator she writes for history of an
Italian quarterly Journal in performing
arts and dance and Anza leading Italian
dance magazine and is the author ability
Jones she also serves on the Editorial
Board of dance research journal and has
participated in the oral history Summer
Institute program here at Columbia so I
know
in the darkness
especially leadership diversity
this is illusion
to focus on us you can visit any context
or 20
and pussycat you see a speck of a samosa
Commerce apology
see